examine what is said not who is speaking
the axe forgets but the tree remembers
don't set sail using someone else's star
do not call a dog with a whip in your
hand
[Music]
once you carry your own water you'll
remember every drop
[Music]
knowledge is a garden if it isn't
cultivated it can't be harvested
a roaring lion kills no game
[Music]
restless feet might walk into a snake
bit
no shortcuts exist to the top of the
palm tree
when two elephants fight it is the grass
that gets hurt
tomorrow belongs to people who prepare
for it today
[Music]
no medicine exists that can cure hatred
all monkeys cannot hang from the same
branch
[Music]
he who digs a grave for his enemy might
as well dig it for himself
even the lion protects himself against
flies
however long the night the dawn will
break
if you heal a person's leg do not be
surprised if they use it to run away
to try and to fail is not laziness
[Music]
seeing is different than being told
no matter how beautiful and well crafted
a coffin might be
it will not make anyone wish for death
wood already touched by fire is not hard
to set a light
[Music]
confining a secret to an unworthy person
is like carrying grain in a bag with a
hole in it
a feeble effort will not fulfill the
self
having a good discussion is like having
wealth
don't think there are no crocodiles just
because the water is calm
he who refuses to obey cannot command
[Music]
one falsehood spoils a thousand truths
the earth is a beehive we all enter by
the same door
rain does not fall on one roof alone
[Music]
however far a stream flows it doesn't
forget its origin
[Music]
if you think you're too small to make a
difference try spending the night with a
mosquito
if there is no enemy within the enemy
outside can do no harm
[Music]
the eye never forgets what the heart has
seen
no person is born great
great people become great when others
are sleeping
[Music]
when an old man dies a library is burned
with him
truth should be in love and love in
truth
when you marry a monkey for his wealth
the money goes but the monkey remains
[Music]
where there is love there is no darkness
when one is in love a cliff becomes a
medal
one who loves you loves you with your
dirt
[Music]
if love is a sickness patience is the
remedy
to love someone who doesn't love you is
like shaking a tree to make the dewdrops
fall
if the full moon loves you why worry
about the stars
don't be so in love that you can't tell
when it's raining
do not treat your loved one like a
swinging door
you are fond of it but you push it back
and forth
love doesn't listen to rumors
[Music]
don't try to make someone hate the
person he loves
he will go on loving but he will hate
you
love doesn't rely on physical features
[Music]
one who plants grapes by the roadside
and one who marries a pretty woman
share the same problem
true love means what's mine is yours
a fish and a bird may fall in love
but the two cannot build a home together
the heart of the wise man lights quiet
like limped water
only a wise person can solve a difficult
problem
in a moment of crisis the wise build
bridges but the foolish build dams
if you are filled with pride then you
will have no room for wisdom
a man who uses force is afraid of
reasoning
wisdom is not like money to be tied up
and hidden
one who causes others misfortune also
teaches them wisdom
a fool cannot untie the knot tied by a
wise man
[Music]
to get lost is to learn the way
if you close your eyes to facts you will
learn through accidents
[Music]
just because the lizard nods its head
doesn't mean he's in agreement
[Music]
a wise man fills his head before
emptying his mouth
[Music]
if you think education is expensive try
ignorance
a fool has to say something
a wise person has something to say
[Music]
a wise man never takes a step too long
for his leg
give advice if people don't listen let
adversity teach them
[Music]
when deeds speak
words are meaningless
a wise person doesn't fall down the same
hill twice
a united family eats from the same plate
a family tie is like a tree
it can bend but it cannot break
[Music]
we desire to bequeath two things to our
children
the first is roots the second is wings
don't meddle with a family feud
a husband with a good wife will never be
on the road without supplies
a small house will hold a hundred
friends
a woman is a flower in a garden her
husband is the fence around it
if you want to go fast go alone
if you want to go far go together
sticks in a bundle are unbreakable
if relatives help each other what evil
can hurt them
home affairs should not be talked about
in the public
square a child does not laugh at the
ugliness of his mother
[Music]
a happy man marries the girl he loves
a happier man loves the girl he married
if a woman doesn't love you she calls
you brother
one who marries for love alone will have
bad days but good nights
[Music]